ma chère famille je vous écris cette
lettre avant de mourir je ne sais pas
exactement quel jour mes proches et moi
moore ont uniquement car nous sommes
juifs
je suis dans un camp de concentration et
nous allons tous être fusillés dans un
abri mardi 4 heures du matin 16 juin
adieu à tous brouilla je faisais
différentes tâches à auschwitz l'une
d'elle consistait à nettoyer les cendres
des lieux où il brûlait les juifs on les
jetait dans une petite rivière
j'y travaille avec un autre gars qui
était déjà adulte il avait 32 ans et moi
j'en avais 16 je ne savais pas d'où
venaient ses cendres un jour je lui ai
demandé qu'est ce que c'est alors il m'a
raconté ce que c'était à ce moment là je
me suis promis que mais reste ne serait
jamais jeter dans cette rivière que je
ferai tout mon possible pour survivre
c'est ce qui me donnait de la force
[Musique]
oui
roche je ne l'oublierai jamais tous les
matins pendant la prière je vois ce
numéro je me vois à auschwitz
[Musique]
non